[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir
si show est une émission qui
s'intéressent au conflit que les couples
peuvent rencontrer dans leur vie
quotidienne dans leur vie de couple au
long d'une vie ce soir nous allons
explorer les problèmes d'un couple sa
vie intime mais nous n'en resterons pas
là ce que psy show essaie de faire ce
que nous essayons de faire de cette
émission c'est d'essayer d'explorer les
mécanismes qui sous-tendent les
relations affectives et au delà du récit
qui va nous être fait ce soir essayez de
comprendre comment ces conflits
s'alimente et bien sûr comment il se
répète
sur ce plateau ce soir nous avons deux
comédiens nous avons un analyste serge
clair une quinzaine de personnes qui
pourront participer à notre notre
émission qui pourrait intervenir dans
courant de cette émission est un couple
bonsoir yvan bonsoir sens one month pas
vous avez quel âge je 31 ans il
françoise que j'ai 29 ans vous avez
quelle profession je travaille au petit
et je suis ambulant
c'est à dire je travaille dans les
trains postaux et france one quel est
votre profession mais pour le moment je
suis étudiante je suis aussi chômeuses
et plus fait différents métiers qui
allait du secrétariat à l'animation
est-ce qu'on peut de façon simple à
résumer le problème qui vous avez eu
d'ennuis est-ce que c'est facile est ce
qu'on peut faire ça c'est très complexe
et en même temps très simple disons que
on voulait on veut vivre ensemble
on veut des enfants on veut
vivre faim de vivre tous les deux vivre
bien se marier et on se pose la question
un jour et le lendemain on ne s'est plus
fait un peu plus vivre ensemble on ne
veut plus marion veut plus d'enfants
mais pour commencer nous allons vous
montrer deux films et deux films que
vous avez écrit l'un et l'autre ils vont
ne sais pas ce qu'ils gardent un film de
françoise françois ne sais pas ce qu'il
ya un film vivant et ce sont nos deux
comédiens qui interprètent vos rôles
je
ils vont tuer trop tourné vers toi même
et y ait une trop grande incompréhension
entre nous j'ai pourtant l'impression de
faire des compromis énorme pour essayer
d'en sortir
je vois que tu arrives à me comprendre
sans passer obligatoirement par les mots
[Musique]
enfin comprendre pourquoi tuer tous ces
blocages pourquoi tu ne vois tes défauts
pourquoi tu te sens toujours insuffisant
alors que tu es tellement de
possibilités je sais que j'en et
mentions
[Musique]
je me souviens du jour nous courions
dans l'eau tous les deux d'un seul coup
tu t'es arrêter ce n'est qu'une heure
après il m'a dit je ne sais pas nager
non sans avoir trouvé plein de prétexte
pour justifier ton attitude
pour la danse est pareil tu sais combien
ça fait partie de moi j'ai voulu tu
apprends messi fille que je veuille
quelque chose pour que tu te bloque
tu aurais pu apprendre avec quelqu'un
d'autre mais tu n'as rien fait
[Musique]
tout semble difficile
si je cherche apte à prendre du temps
inférieur écrasé par mois si je ne fais
rien tu ne bouge pas
dans nos rapports c'est la même chose si
je prends sur moi lettres tendres parce
que je sens que tu en as besoin alors
que moi je ne suis pas très disponible
tu m'en voudras tueur a l'impression de
te fait une fleur
ils disent
comme ça
j'ai l'impression que tout notre couple
repose sur mes épaules si je dis je
t'aime tu dis on s'aime si je n'aime pas
tu dis on s'aime pas
tu es tellement bloquée que je n'arrive
pas à avoir un rapport de femme avec toi
et ça maintenant je ne peux plus le
supporter
m
je veux pouvoir être moi-même en face de
toi sans crainte
m
[Musique]
c'est vrai j'ai du mal à te parler
directement même quand tu n'es pas là
j'éprouve c'est sur le besoin de mettre
une certaine distance entre toi et moi
ainsi françoise je ne te parlerai pas
directement
aujourd'hui encore je suis en retard
pourquoi françoise profitent elles
toujours des heures qui précèdent le
départ pour lancer la discussion
chaque fois nous sommes devenus des
stakhanovistes de la dispute
cette nuit par exemple jusqu'à 4 heures
du matin mais là par jet de l'épongé je
me suis endormi en balbutiant des
phrases mille fois dit
quand j'ai rencontré françoise j'étais
dans une situation difficile je venais
d'en prendre plein la gueule je t'ai
vécu comme ces missionnaires arrive en
afrique au sec dernier évangélisant un
coup de canon et le goupillon
[Musique]
françoise voulais me sauver de mes
problèmes mais ces problèmes je faisais
bien l'utiliser pour ne pas m'impliquer
je demandais alors c'était de me
récupérer de vivre de m'éclater
quand tout semblait aller je me
dépêchais de dire que je ne savais pas
si je t'ai mais hélas mon indépendance
réaffirmé je me sentais bien
c'est déjà là
il faut que je me suis que ce bordel
c'est pas le bandage
j'ai déjà mangé à la fac avec des
copains j'ai pas faim
je croyais qu'elle voulait le pouvoir
me disait que j'étais petit elle me
critique est constamment pour moi
c'était un rapport de force
peut-être qu'au fond je recherche le
pouvoir c'est vrai j'aime dominé les
gemmes dominé quelqu'un qui peut
toujours me faire tomber
[Musique]
le propulsant la poudre
j'ai l'impression que nous avançons et
que nous nous consolider
[Musique]
bien
est ce que est ce que dans ces deux
films
vous avez dit des choses que vous vous
étiez pas dit avant
à vrai dire je pars
pas très bien saisi ce qu'a voulu dire
vous ne comprenez pas ce qu'il veut dire
dans le film we
est ce que c'est une situation qui nous
arrive souvent la vie quotidienne très
souvent
je pense qu'ils vont s'exprime d'une
certaine façon que j'ai
souvent du mal à comprendre et je vais
pas me lever à chaque fois pour chercher
un dictionnaire parce que commencer et
en plus c'est pas uniquement au niveau
des mots c'est je pense que c'est tout
une forme de
sa façon de s'exprimer qui je suppose je
est ce que c'est la même chose pour vous
ils vont exposer à la passion qu'elle
vous connaît bien qu'elle vous comprends
bien ou au contraire est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment que bon c'est pas ça
non plus il y à il ya eu la période
auxerre rencontré des difficultés de
compréhension hier justement vous vous
l'avez ressenti comme langue anglaise
la première chose qui m'a le plus étonné
c'était son absence de
son absence de
[Musique]
je vais dire rides mais c'est parce que
c'est parce que je veux dire
son absence de vie sur par rapport à mon
visage à moi à part un village d'autres
gens
neutres
je me suis dit ou alors c'est
je chose que j'ai pensé c'est une
menteuse génial
ou alors c'est quelqu'un vraiment de
passionnant qui finalement a choisi
l'autre là
je pense que je me suis posée vous êtes
imposé de quelle façon
de toutes les façons
bon en plus je voulais y vont pourquoi
j'ai entendu lee vont parler bon comme
ça j'ai découvert quelqu'un qui était
totalement différent de ce que j'avais
vu de ce type bon un peu prétentieux un
peu pédant que comme ça que j'ai
découvert quelqu'un de très sensible et
très malheureux enfin c'est ce que moi
je pensais je sais pas il y avait une
approche très très douce de de la vie
très doux se fait très mal à vous
décrire comme quelqu'un de sensible de
d'émouvant qui est donc à vous ses
faiblesses comment expliquer cette
différence entre cette perception est
celle que vous dites dans le film disons
qu'il ya eu quelque chose qui moi m'a
beaucoup étonné bon j'ai vécu avec yvon
pendant je crois un an et demi ou deux
ans
et pour moi c'était fabuleux c'était
pratiquement s'était assise juridique
c'était des pommes de terre non non
juste un tout petit point française
c'était l'époque on faisait envie de
tout le monde voilà et avoue jours ils
vont m'a dit stop c'est pas ça
je vraiment j'employais vraiment le gros
calibres gt gt dit je me pose des
questions sur l'amour que j'ai pour toi
au matin il était plus que ça j'ai dit
je t'aime fort oui voilà ça a été
vraiment pour moi ça a été
et qu'est ce qui vous a pris juin je
demandais de pouvoir donner est de
pouvoir de recevoir ou moment je n'avais
envie je vous disais ouhlala
bon je me suis moins impliquées qu'elles
ans attise aventure elle s'implique de
plus en plus est
je suis en train de me faire avoir la
françoise cantet yvan vous a dit au bout
d'un an et demi de ce qui avait semblé
pour vous être une période d'
extrêmement heureuse vous a dit si je ne
marche plus j'avais pu jouer ça
m'intéresse pas qu'est ce que vous avez
fait c'est pas très très bien mais je
pense que j'ai essayé de comprendre bon
c'est de comprendre et de je crois que
de là est partie cette espèce de
un nouveau type de relation entre nous
qui était qui était basé sur moi
j'essayais de comprendre
ce qu'est ce qu'ils vont me disait ou
comment ça se fait qu'il sentait mal
enfin tu sais je jouais le mec en
détresse le mec en détresse le mec paumé
qui était vrai et sur certains points
mais qui ne l'était pas ce point là et
je vais demander qu'elle me prennent en
charge
j'ai compris qu'il y ait commencé à
râler
jeu donc je le laisse jamais sur un
terrain sur un type de rapport qui était
qui n'était pas un type de rapports
hommes femmes
donc de ce fait je me suis réfugié dans
un type de rapport qui était enfant
enfin mr qui mettait beaucoup plus
facile et que quelque part me
satisfaisait et qui quelque part là
cette estimation tout ça où tu n'en est
pas réellement conscients rend fou c'est
pas être bon mais je le dis avec le
recul je suis pas machiavélique à ce
point négatif n'est pas prise sur des
polices je ne t'ai pas prise sur le
passant dans la rue tiens celle là est
et on a construit un écheveau dans
lequel l'ensemble pétré moi même je me
suis empêtré et que nos bêtes le nom je
pense que tu t'es vous fêterez on
n'avait pas fait le couple lui tout seul
tenant une place au super bowl
décret aussi je tente rennais sur un
terrain c'est bien ce que dit quand tu
dis on a construit vous allez laisser
traîner quelque chose d'autre vous
pouvez trier partir si ça vous plaît
situation pourquoi mais c'est pour ça
que c'est que c'était une cuve et enfin
qu'un passage à vide comme tout le monde
peut avoir bon ça va pas trop faim et
c'est pas
parce que finalement quand je disais que
ça m'est arrivé des fois devenir bon je
me casse comme par hasard les problèmes
disparaissait
enfin bon il m'est arrivé une fois de
lui dire que bon si ce n'est pas le dire
comme ça parce que c'est à dire attends
tu veux que je te dise je me rattrape
pas je suis de le dire beaucoup mieux
enfin beaucoup de bien
pour ça pour que ça passe mieux parce
que bon ça peut dire trois mots mais bon
c'est trois mois c'est difficile à faire
passer
bon c'est vrai que nous avons nous
étions physiquement assez loin c'est une
période ont travaillé pas mal
et on n'avait plus aucune vraiment une
rancune relation physique c'était
vraiment je peux pas dire à la sauvette
c'est vrai que physiquement on était
fatigué et puis un jour
[Musique]
françoise mahdi en avait marre elle m'a
dit écoute si tu si tu t'endors tu dis
que tu as couché même avant
situé en dehors d'un cul mais la tête
sur l'oreiller
je suis désolé mais je suis obligée
d'aller voir quelqu'un d'autre et puis
le puits sommeil
c'était le genre de situation qu
effectivement j'étais obligé de temps en
temps d'en donner un peu pour pour
appâter le pour appâter le client enfin
c'est vrai mais comment vous avez réussi
justement un transformé un peu ce
rapport là et à durer encore trois
années
un peu ce que je me vais fort
je pense qu'on est allé au bout et que
c'est qu'il faut être mais dicté avait
compris que en ayant cette attitude là
tu t'empêcher de finalement d'avoir
plein de choses agréables c'est sur wii
à ça aussi fins et qu il est pas bon je
me suis tout ce que je pouvais avoir
enfin parce que je pouvais avoir dans
une relation avec quelqu'un et je l'a
placé sur un terrain qui ne quittait pas
est un cul de sac afin qu'ils servent mr
bean obligatoirement que de ça
bien les comédiens qui ont été à
l'écouté de niveau et françoise vont
sans doute pouvoir improviser maintenant
quelque chose sur ce qui vient d'être
dit
c'est vraiment sympa les dents cette
poupée qui va faire justement j'y pense
et j'ai vu dans la boutique
s'était fait plaisir des chemins mais
j'aurais peut-être préfère un blur m'a
enfin bon c'est pas mal
vous n'avez pas ça pas changé non c'est
bien
fais gaffe aux carrefours enfin j'ai
jamais attention carrefour un coup de
françoise je conduis d'abord ce n'est
pas un carrefour j'appelle ça une
intersection
carrefour
intersections et associant c't'un gars
faut commencer moins élévé la première
tu vois tout la première tour obtient
règne de faire craquer cette boîte de
vitesses trop douce terre c'est ma
bagnole et s'était cassé la boîte de
vitesses moi j'en rate pas mais françois
je suis d'accord mais c'est ton genou
qui m'empêche de passer les vitesses un
couple est à tapis sur mon pied c'est
pas le frein en plus t'es marrant du
coup on est vraiment comme un piège
je sais tu veux conduire d'accord non tu
conduiras pas
la faillite avait un short très bonne
fin mais freine pas les plantes des
normands derrière
bon j'arrête
je suis pas conduire non tu sais pas
conduit à toucher bien d'ailleurs quand
je t'ai connu tu avais un vélo
avance maintenant sévère non mais soit
je sais conduire et je repars
soit je ne sais pas conduire et je
m'arrête alors que tu as raté je conduis
non je crois que tu n'as pas compris ce
que je voulais dire la première fois je
disais que si tu avais envie de conduire
tu ne pouvais pas conduire la partir de
ce moment là je prenais le volant
c'était très clair pour toi je comprends
rien mais pourtant c'est simple je
prends le volant
je mets des clés de contact ouais bah ça
d'accord dont le parti a aussi trouvé
toujours à seven starter heureusement
que tu es
belle rosie quelle galère vraiment
unique décor y est je t'adore
c'est pas mal et des très bons trucs je
crois qu'ici nous a raconté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et elle a les moins chers que toi
non c'est moi c'est sûr que c'est au
niveau de l'impro bossé très et maurice
tic
il n'y a pas le dialogue comme ça répond
il enfin il n'ya pas parle pas
ne pas parler chinois
serait pour moi parce que je le
pathologique je pense que c'est une a
grillé une agression
parce qu'avec une agression enfin
un jour sans piétons
tu m'as dette comprend très bien
françois ce que je ne suis pas habitué à
ce genre ce mode d'expression tu connais
mon
enfance et ma famille où tout se passait
en demi teinte et
et où mes parents font une
tirade honneur extrêmement
important du qui ne sont que jamais 10
pratiquement jamais discuté dans toute
leur vie
moi je leur dise c'est juré dit c'est
aussi grave que de se disputer en 64
bon et le non-dit enfin bon et ça
il est vrai que moi je ne suis pas
habitué pour moi on se dispute on sait
va très mal et c'est vrai françois ce
que vous connaissez bien sans son
histoire son enfance ses parents
je crois je les voie moi
commisson mais je peux dire je connais
bien sa mère je connais le banc le
mal qu'elle a pu faire avec vous je
connais son père aussi le mal qu'il a pu
faire mais d'un autre côté je je
comprends aussi sa mère parce que bon
c'est une femme et je peux comprendre
les les revendications qu'elle avait
roulé désir qu'a l'avait et je comprends
aussi son père donc c'est
il faut préciser que mes parents sont
paysans étaient paysans d'une génération
de début du xi la clé sont nés au début
du siècle il était une fois voilà est
propriétaire propriétaire kerjean en
bourgogne dans l'yonne
c'était des gens qui étaient
mon qui avait une qui était très dur à
la tâche et il n'avait pas le temps la
limite de discuter de discuter de parler
il y avait des relations les plus
personnels dans le nouveau site et votre
talent votre maman c'est une autre mère
parce qu'elle était avec nous c'est elle
qui veut le plus élevé elle était restée
à la maison mon père était parti tout
était dans les choux faire comme lui
j'ai un frère c'est
justement comment vous voyez votre mère
qu'elle engendre la sueur vous aviez
avec elle
ma mère ce que n'a jamais eu et n'a
jamais su exprimer ses sentiments
profonds sur l'affectivité et n'arrivait
pas à l'écrit mais ça ne sourit même pas
et
comment dire le vous le sentiez quand
même comment est-ce que l'exprimé d'une
manière détournée voilà elle l'utilisé
ma mère est née je pense à la fait très
longtemps de la cuisine pour nous
prouver c'est l'amour qu'elle ressentait
pour ma mère s'est fait la cuisine pour
cela je voudrais te dire quelque chose
que qui vient à l'esprit tu as dit quand
vous lui avez demandé s'il avait
l'impression que sa mère l'aiment et se
dit le oui est il ya quelques fins il ya
quelques jours quand je t'ai rencontré
ou même il ya pas si longtemps que ça
n'était pas aussi je pense qu'elle va
nous a profondément aimé nous sommes
profondément
mais n'a pas su
exprimer ses sentiments d'amour et l'a
aimé profondément je dirais presque les
des statuts c'est une marge de 7,8
d'albâtre qu'elle a adoré l adorer des
statuts c'était ses enfants vous aviez
une statue oui pour allouer je crois que
la mère divorcée est aussi quelqu'un qui
a qui a été terriblement déçu par par
plein plein de choses pour elle une vie
extrêmement dur ce sont des gens qui ont
connu deux guerres mon père s'il a connu
deux guerres et ma mère a connu la
seconde guerre mondiale et sa mère enfin
là ma grand mère maternelle s'est
suicidé
à cause de la seconde guerre mondiale
comme ça elle s'est suicidée la pose de
la deuxième guerre mondiale aient peur
pour sa fille
lorsque les allemands oui lorsque les
allemands sont arrivés dans la région
tamare thiboutot six autres sous l'ère
dite aussi autre chose c'est que sa
fille mère a été malheureux certainement
les suicides et parce que son mari un
petit capital elles parce qu'elles se
sont des gens qui l'utilisent utile et
next tout doit être utile tout doit
passer par l'utilité tout doit avoir une
utilité je crois qu'en plus ta mère
avait mis beaucoup beaucoup d'espoir
dans
dans sa vie avec donc avec son avec son
mari et à cette époque là je crois
qu'elle ait commencé un petit peu
a revendiqué elle voulait déjà autre
chose que cette espèce de chose comme ça
le lavia la samarie partie les moines
dans tous les coins enfin bon elle avait
déjà une envie de confort elle avait une
envie aussi de d'avoir envie elle
voulait lui plaisait à le volet de la
jouissance elle voulait elle dit par
exemple c'était un petit exemple quel
site elle dit yeux quand je disais
pourquoi elle est comment ça se fait
qu'ils n'avaient pas eu plus d'enfants
parce que pas de contraception et c'est
raté et souvent elle dit en dardant sont
mariés ou même quand elle me regarde et
me dit mais toute façon on a déjà eu du
mal en faire deux parce qu'ils avaient
assez peu de temps elle dit des choses
comme ça qui sont acquis pour moi
quand elle me dit ça j'ai vraiment
beaucoup d'élan d'élan vers elle est
vraiment je crois que c'est une faute de
cas qui a beaucoup souffert bon et ça
mes parents disent on a pris conscience
maintenant que c'est flagrante que nous
ils sont à la retraite qui pense à eux
et un imagier très drôle
maintenant qu'on a le temps on ne peut
plus
c'était pas dit ça c'est vrai ils en ont
pris conscience
[Musique]
et ce qui subsiste quelque chose de ce
que vous étiez comme comme enfant comme
adresse je pense que
ce qu'on a ce qu'on ne m'a pas appris
c'est le contact avec les autres je
dirais aussi bien contact physique que
le contact
je dirais humain enfin humain donc est
ce qui me restait c'est le contact
intellectuelle
vous vous êtes intéressé à
elle invitait la vie de françoise
wii est là
parce que le rapport on était plus
encore plus accentué plus
bon c'était vraiment j'étais vraiment
très dur enfin je commence à perdre foi
et sa mère oui en plus elle avait pris
son père c'était comment
c'était
j'ai presque envie de dire c'était pas
c'était pas la femme c'était pas
ma mère ne m'a absolument pas désirer
elle a vraiment fait tout tout tout tout
ce qui était possible et imaginable et
même pas at il encore plus après ce
qu'elle a dit pour ne pas voter pour ne
pas m'avoir
quant à mon père
voulait un garçon
manque de chance c'est une fille et
ma mère à bonds a rendu mon père
responsable effectivement d'avoir un
autre enfant c'est à dire moi et en plus
elle m'en a voulu à moi parce que bon
j'étais là et qu'il fallait qu'elle
recommence sa vie de ma mère en plus
d'une femme qui vient d'un milieu très
très très pauvres qui a voulu bon
qu'ironie complètement ça tout ça
ses origines ses origines
et elle a vraiment fait tout pour ça et
là bon l âme et mon père dehors
il a viré pour voyez pourquoi les pays
bas parce que chaleureux suppose que mon
père empêcher un petit peu ma mère de
2 ii du livre ce qu'ils voulaient vivre
c'est-à-dire s'est levé s'est levé s'est
levé s'est levé en fin de mois le plus
avoir oublié ses origines dont elle
travaillait elle voulait avoir de
l'argent
la nuit le jour le premier comprimé peut
pas dormir mais quand même je pense que
j'aurais peut-être pu essayer de faire
attention que j'existais un petit peu
quand même
au bout d'un certain temps dans ma mère
s'est remariée avec quelqu'un bon elana
maire a vraiment pris conscience du
apparemment du poids que j'étais pour à
elle bon parce que des jamais reprocher
beaucoup de choses dont j'étais à cause
de son malheur la cause de mon père
était partie la cause que vous n'avez
pas d'argent parce que et c'est tout
tout était de ma faute
et là effectivement voilà comment elle
s'est mariée avec quelqu'un qui est
aussi avec quelques petits problèmes
affectifs
elle a carrément matière allemand
sacrifier c'est à dire qu'au bout d'un
certain temps elle m'a dit tu prends tes
valises et tu casses sympathique oui à
tikrit et finalement quand je me suis
retrouvé dehors j'avais rien j'avais un
ticket de métro et j'avais une valise
que ma mère m'avait donné fait marrer
fait et je me souviens que quand ma mère
m'a dit bah t'as qu'à partir parce que
j'étais moins que rien j'aurais donné la
moitié de ma vie pourquoi mr brise
rasteau là et finalement prendre elle
m'a pas dit de rester en pro 6 est
géré sur mes saisons vous saviez tout ça
et moi j'ai bon j'ai connu sa mère j'ai
l'impression que c'est quelqu'un qui a
qui s'est senti piégé par ses trois
enfants et particulièrement par la
dernière vous avez des relations avec ma
mère parce qu'effectivement je montrais
le plus affectif possible le plus bon
j'avais énormément énormément énormément
vairelles donc finalement elle était
quand même obligé de me donner parce que
c'était parce que vous demandiez qu'elle
veut donner quelque chose ou voulu
obliger presque parmi bompard par an par
mon affective par ma part ma gentillesse
par la douceur parce qu'on parle partout
ça pour je me vendait déjà à l'époque je
commençais j'ai commencé a démarré comme
ça il s'avère qu'il faut donner pour
avoir et
même plus parce que vraiment pour elle
venait peu et stone est vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et
il c'est vrai que enfin quand je dis que
je me vendait bon je pensais pas ça
quand j'étais plus jeune parce que
j'avais pas la réflexion oui je crois
que c'est ça j'ai commencé à me vendre
d'abord à ma mère et puis ensuite vous
et c'est quelque chose que vous sentez
encore maintenant
un an non non je pense que ça
je pense que c'est resurgit un tout
petit peu parce que quand je dis qu'au
début c'est vrai quand j'étais dit au
début que nous étions ensemble que je
voulais la par exemple un autonomie que
je voulais l'indépendance
et que je n'étais pas prêt à me lancer
dans une relation
assez forte bon je pense que tu as été
oblige été mise au pied du mur et tu as
été obligé de me donner énormément pour
que non tu ne vis pas comme ça d'abord
parce que tu fais pas ce que tu dis
c'était page aimons notre mini c'était
tout faire ce que je veux mais il faut
que
le sac à dos s'ouvre au moment où je
mangeais pas
mais ça c'est la plupart des gens comme
ça
et aujourd'hui la maintenant dans vos
relations entre moi comment ça
fonctionne le couple
comment ça marche
comment dire c'est
tjrs en dents de scie s'ils ont donc si
c'est fin cette tâche particulièrement
dans steam qui donne qui reçoit qui
commence à se partagent un exemple entre
autres je vais conserver une des
manières d'exprimer mon affection pour
quelqu'un pour les gens que j'aime
telus faire la cuisine
soutien point 2 bis qui se tient à
préciser aux efforts que je n'aime pas
manger
que je mange pas beaucoup et que le mois
alors ça se voit c'est bien faire la
cuisine mais franchement passer deux ou
trois heures à table
j'apprécie pas et c'est une des choses
que françoise à l'ampleur du problème
n'a pas vraiment compris et à
ne pas dire à mal reçus mais reçu une
manière donc n'attendez pas et je sais
que il y à de nombreuses situations qui
ont été comme ça qui ont fait que
finalement on est arrivé à vraiment la
compréhension alors que c'est enfin
c'est des petites choses mais toutes ces
petites choses que ce soit avant de tous
côtés d'yvon du mien
vraiment fait que l'on s'est retrouvé
dans une
prison pris une importance n'a pas non
non et entre autres j'ai découvert un
moyen fabuleux pour moi pour m'exprimer
qui me correspondait bien qu'ils étaient
la danse est pour moi la danse c'est
quelque chose ça fait vraiment partie de
moi c'est
vraiment presque genre en plus et ils
vont de danse pas je ressentais très
très très mal le fait qu'ils ne danse
pas et enfin même pas feint même qu'il
essaye pas je veux dire
parce que c'était pas seulement bon
enfin je dirais limite j'aurais très
bien pu lui apprendre le rock le tango
bon ça s'apprend il suffit de faire 3 4
pas ça s'apprend
mais bon c'est vrai qu'il y avait un
blocage par rapport à moi
là dessus et moi je voulais vraiment lui
apprendre comment je voulais lui
apprendre mais dire tout mon amour s'il
était là dedans quoi j'avais envie de
lui j'avais envie de lui lui procurer le
plaisir qu'ils pourraient avoir parce
que le ce mode d'expression c'est à
votre expression que je vais jamais
utilisé je connaissais pas
non non mais je pense que ça va venir
très vite trouvée il s'inscrit pas mal
de bruit il a depuis quelques minutes du
côté du public et peut-être que ce
serait bien de leur passé la parole on
s'impatiente là derrière
moi je voudrais dire que j'ai eu
l'impression à ce sujet que françoise
devait donner beaucoup pour recevoir et
ça me renvoie énormément à moi parce que
j'avais l'habitude de donner beaucoup
comme ça la personne à qui je donne et
mettez et m ont obligé et j'avais un
certain pouvoir sur lui
et je n'arrivais pas avoir de relation
adulte avec les personnes de données
quand j'avais envie c'était dans le but
d'avoir
ce qui m'a pas surprise mais intéressé
lorsqu'il disait de françoise c'est
quand elle dit je j'étais obligé de me
vendre une première fois il se vendait à
sa maman une deuxième fois elle
s'imposait yvon et je voulais savoir si
d'or son rapport avec les jeunes avec
toujours le sentiment de devoir forcer
pour être acceptée ou si des fois il lui
arrivait d'être acceptée telle qu'elle
était sans faire le forcing parce que
moi aussi j'ai souvent l'impression de
faire le forcing pour être accepté par
les autres non moi je fais pas le
forcing pour être accepté par les autres
bons jeux
je replace un petit peu les choses je
disais que j'avais voulu être avec qui
voit là que je me suis donné les moyens
pour les affres un bon mais je me suis
pas vendu je me suis pas ou enfin pour
avoir pour avoir l'affection de votre
mère enfin le peu qu'elle ne pouvait
vous donner il fallait vous vendre et
non mais moi j'achète
enfin moi j'ai remarqué quelque chose va
je les trouve tous les deux très très
sympathique jeu c'est merci ce que je
voulais dire c'est que ce qui m'a frappé
c'est que quand françoise parle elle
n'écoute jamais y vont mais quand ils
vont parle vous pensez que françoise
n'est pas attentif à yvan voilà
mais elle veut toujours intervenir sans
titre parle voilà elle veut toujours
enfin je sens qu'elle est enfin j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est anxieux ya de
toujours lui dire mais si mais ça se
passe comme si ça se passe comme ça et
moi j'ai trouvé qu'il avait un regard
extrêmement amoureux et tendre quand
elle parlait voilà
moi ce que je voudrais dire à françoise
c'est que il semble que ta souffrance
quelque part tu n'en veux pas tu la
refuse
tu acceptes qu'elle vienne à cause du
couple mais tu as l'air de refuser et
moi ça me paraît essentiel qu'elle vient
en réalité de toi
et je voudrais savoir ce que tu en
penses de ça
c'est votre propre sentiment quand même
par rapport à cela oui parce que je vais
peut-être lui dire pourquoi parce que
moi je me suis trompé très longtemps à
penser toujours
par exemple dans le couple ma souffrance
c'était la faute de l'autre bon ça
arrive je le concède mais d'une façon
générale
j'ai appris il m'a fallu du temps pour
le comprendre que c'était en réalité ma
souffrance
je peux répondre
je
sais pas je suis venu ici pour
pour peaux différentes choses
pour qu'elles aient aussi parce que
quelque chose justement on pourrait
d'abord parce que j'ai vécu un certain
type de relation avec quelqu'un
je parle pour moi qui qui m'a fait
d'avoir beaucoup de mal cette relation
m'a fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de mal
et j'ai voulu j'ai voulu comprendre
pourquoi
donc j'ai fait toute une toute une
démarche entre autres celle qui est ici
et je sais que moi par rapport à par
rapport à yvon quelque chose que par
exemple je n'arrive pas à comprendre
c'est toutes ces difficultés qu'il dit
avoir et qu'il a peut-être
et je
tout ce qu'il a dit et tout ce que tout
ce que vous avez dit et tout ce qu'on
m'a dit ne m'a toujours pas fait
comprendre
fait beaucoup de mal on a vraiment
l'impression qu'il ya quelques tares
beaucoup de mal non c'est ça m'a fait
beaucoup de mal dans le sens où ça bon
ça m'a bon je dirais pas que ça m'a fait
vieillir mais c'est vrai que ça m'a fait
vieillir ça m'a fait ça m'a fait
abandonner toute une
toute une idée que j'avais dans la tête
sur la conception d'un couple sur ce que
c'était qu'un couple sur ce que sur
l'homme
je trouve qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
d'égoïsme
dans cette
dans cette vie dans notre vie à nous et
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup d'égoïsme
dans la vie des gens de tout le monde
enfin de tous les couples je crois qu'il
ya pas ya
mama seuls gérants mon seul but avec
avec yvon ça a été d'essayer d'atteindre
une
c'était d'essayer d'atteindre un bonheur
s comprend pas pourquoi quand vous n'y
arrivez pas non
qu'est ce qui vous empêche d'être d'être
heureux sur quels points à gauche
c'est pas un point
je crois que
je me dit quelque part en moi que je ne
sais pas être heureux
peut-être que je sais pas non plus
et vous avez envie
de lui et j'en faisais rien apprendre du
tout de lui apprendre j'ai pas envie de
lui apprendre quoi que ce soit
matrix à vienne je voudrais rien je ne
sais pas dire pour moi tout ça c'est
tellement abstraite toutes ses phrases
c'est pas il ya
elle est à tout ce qui me passe
complètement au dessus de la tête
j'écoute j'ai beau écouter mais j'arrive
pas j'arrive vraiment pas à comprendre
bon jeu peut-être que ça fait encore mal
interprété mais nous sommes que l'amour
des femmes
ça
c'est pas ça ça leur donne des détails
des tas de possibilités et apparemment
l'amour des hommes
ça leur donne pas beaucoup de
possibilités ou de volonté
lorsque lorsqu'ils vont des fois on peut
me reprocher bon tu vois pas mon amour
ou que bon qu'il ne perçoit pas je crois
qu'il fait pas très très attention en
vérité elle a vu notre couple et à la à
la vie quotidienne
quand on me dise qu'on rencontre le
canon public a dit
qu' il me semblait que je n'écoutais pas
ils vont j'ai eu envie de me lever et de
lui dire vous savez ce que c'est que
d'écouter quelqu'un pendant quatre ans
sans jamais jamais avoir une réponse ni
même un mot
il me semble qu'effectivement j'ai bon
j'ai pas voulu aider y vont parce que ça
c'est complètement faux je crois que
j'ai voulu les mets
et ça mais
ça m'est retombé dessus comme un
con
je ne sais rien en tout cas ça va tomber
sur la gueule quelque chose de très très
fort et
puis on est là à discuter comme ça de
choses et d'autres mais il me semble
qu'ils moins qu'un petit peu de
lait vérité et de c'est pas
moi j'ai pas il me semble que j'ai
répété souvent elles y vont quand on
aime quelqu'un
il ya rien qui est impossible
[Musique]
comment on pourrait décrire les
relations que vous avez
vous avez bien décrit d'ailleurs les
choses que vous n'arrivez pas à faire
ensemble par exemple bon la cuisine
tellement choqué ce que vous faites
ensemble quels sont les moments dans
votre vie commune où vous éprouver du
plaisir ensemble
c'est le moment où
[Musique]
peut-être que que tous les deux on
s'abandonne on s'abandonne à l'autre et
sans
sang se vivre ils vont françois sans se
vivre enfin si elles se vivent ils
volent yvon et françoise mais sans se
vivre une femme enfin quelque part il ya
ça c'est sûr je pense que toute une
raison pour que je vive pas avec toi et
aucune raison pour que j'ai pas de coup
j'ai un enfant avec toi il ya aucune
raison pour pas que je fasse ma vie avec
toi je pourrais aussi bien dire le
contraire
c'est sûr que notre couple enfin moi je
pense là pendant que tu peux relève
françoise c'est sûr que notre couple
dans un schéma beaucoup plus
classique je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
moins de problèmes il y aurait eu
beaucoup moins de problèmes si françoise
ne et site était une femme
si j'étais une femme c'était bon attends
je vais faire les uns
si j'étais une petite et une femme dit
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une fois oui non
mais je comprends pas dans quelle
optique venir
et je sais comment cesser voilà c'est le
type même de deux choses qui bloquent
jeudi quelque chose qui est bon et je
pose une question c'était une femme me
dit si c'était une femme célèbre eux
ça peut
dans le sens est ce que tu penses que
nous prend le problème serait le même
enfin une autre coupe serait le problème
de notre couple cgt à la même si une
femme non pas aussi une femme et toi tu
serais quoi une femme ou six ans on
était deux femmes voilà vous voyez que
ça s'est inversé les rôles grâce au
rebond
mais ça complètement différent on
connaît beaucoup moins c'est évident
voilà déjà un peu je le pense mais c'est
ça c'est sûr et ça bon je pense que
c'est françoise ne revendiquez pas si
si tu as et la vessie l'assiette ctq si
elle avait accepté ce que je vous
propose au début il y aura pas eu ces
problèmes ce genre de pense aussi ce
mal-être 2 que tu as deux d'être de dom
c'est vachement dur d'être un moment je
c'est vrai que quand on perd pied moi je
sens que quelque part je perds pied et
c'est vrai que les rôles ne sont là je
dirais la limite que les rôles ne sont
plus aussi ne sont plus claires
françoise vous poser la question si tu
étais femmes
être femme est ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'on est je crois moi pas seulement
quand on est psychanalyste
je crois que tout le monde est d'un côté
hommes d'un côté femmes
et c'est le rapport entre ils vont d'un
côté entre françoise de l'autre
officiellement femmes hommes qui ont en
même temps chacun un côté hommes d'un
côté femmes et comment est-ce qu'on
accepte comment est ce qu'on vit le côté
de de ce qu'on n'est pas
j'ai l'impression qu'ils font il se
donne pas les moyens
de
c'est de ses envies ou de ces
désherbants et c'est un homme qui veut
être aimé qui veut être à la fois bon
forts faibles qui veut une certaine
fabrique ya des tas de détails besoin
d'être désir comme comme tout à chacun
qui qui qui se connaît mais qui
n'arrivent pas à
faire avec tout ce qu'il est avec c'est
pour ça qu'ils vont une raison pour
laquelle je suis ici enfin nous sommes
ici c'est que je revendique le droit
effectivement à l'erreur c'est une des
choses qui a plu à françoise
revendiquait le droit à l'erreur je
revendique le droit me trompe de me
tromper nous ne pas être un mal par fait
de ne pas être un homme parfait ne pas
mettre un
policier
oui je peux peut-être une époque je m'en
suis inscrit je suis tombé dans
l'extrême inverse je m'en suis servi
pour dire bon par facilité c'est vrai
qu'on peut s'en servir on peut retourner
sur quels points alors êtes-vous parfait
ensemble puisque rien n'est parfait et
bien un endroit où ça va aller
merveilleusement puisque j'ai souvent
l'impression d'être les autres contre
les autres
c'est vrai c'est vrai bon je pense que
des jeux ont sali toujours face à un
ennemi commun vous faites votre unité
par rapport au moins l'extérieur
du bus votre activité vous avez des
problèmes pour vous rencontrer
effectivement on est et on avait tous on
avait je dirais qu'à la limite on avait
tout pour ce que c'est la gueule enfin
tu étais si tu étais extrêmement
différente de moi
en soi se disait l'autre fois
je me lance et ensuite je regarde
derrière
et moi dans le côté
bon c'est peut-être l'athéisme paysans
mai
je regarde j'analyse et je me lance je
dirais presque à coup sûr
effectivement je fais beaucoup moins de
choses je fais beaucoup moins de choses
quel jeu
non le sait ça
combien de temps ils ont en tout cas
fait deux ans
que je comprends pas c'est cet éternel
s'étonnait chaque fois quoique qu'on
parle que je te parle tant que tuque
d'aventuré expliquer quelque chose que
j'ai compris parce que je me l'a rabâché
depuis si vraiment j'avais pas compris
c'est que c'est vrai non mais tu l'avais
pas dit qu'il accepte pas non parce que
il ya certaines choses qui n'est pas
faillir ya un certain comportement comme
celui des bons comme celui d'état
méfiance comme celui de bon il ya tout
un tas de choses comme ça qui existent
encore alors que les raisons que tu
évoquais ou que tu évoques pour dire
pour pour expliquer pourquoi tu étais
comme ça mais ne ont disparu
mais oui mais par contre tu aimes les
sciences à laquelle reste toujours tu te
faire mon moindre au moindre chose c'est
ça si tu veux comme moi j'arrive pas
j'ai l'impression que ça se passe comme
ça tout le temps parce que d'un autre
côté vous dites que vous en avez marre
mais elle en a marre aussi d'entendre le
discours elle voudrait qu'il se passe
quelque chose enfin c'est ce que
l'inserm non
alors j'ai envie de poser la question
voulait sûrement déjà posée et si vous
faisiez un enfant qu'est-ce qui se
passerait
on verra peut-être un peu plus tard on
verra un peu plus tard parce que
ça qu'il faut qu'on aille l'un au bout
de l'autre mais la question c'est déjà
posé comme ça explicitement bien sûr et
en qualité trois jours après j'ai
rencontré trois quatre jours après je
les rencontre et je lui ai dit je vais
te faire un enfant
il ya aussi
je pense que pour avoir un enfant c'est
comme pour être
je n'attaque pas du tout serge diverses
occasions pense que pour être psychiatre
psychanalyste il faut avoir atteint une
certaine maturité
je pense qu accomplir et je pense que
par un enfant il faut avoir atteint une
certaine maturité j'ai vu des gens à 25
ans peuvent l'avoir atteint mais l'ado
que je pense à 50 ans ils n'ont jamais
atteint il est donc vous histoire géo
instrument c'est un chose parce que
quand vous êtes des gens ça drôlement
bouleversé le couple comment je dis
quand vous êtes nsa drôlement bouleversé
aux parents oui et puis essaoui et puis
c'est tout c'est un rapport à la fête
qu'on va pas d'enfant nous coucher
patick vous ne vouliez pas ni que j'en
sais rien c'est une question que je pose
je sais pas pourquoi n'a pas d'enfant
bon parce que d'abord on voudrait bien
faire l'appartement parce que en ce
moment on n'a pas beaucoup de fric parce
que tu en entends bon avec yvon il ya
des hauts il ya des bas parce que j'ai
pas fini mes études parce qu'il est un
travail qui permet pas d'eux parce qu'on
en veut de travailler ensemble et que
pour le moment on travaille à ça
voilà il ya tout un tas de choses
d'habitude
c'est toujours liée aussi aux questions
comme vous disiez de vos question de
fric au sein mais pour vous actuellement
pour fait le partenaire
j'ai cru comprendre vous êtes d'accord
ou est ce qu'il ya des est ce que vous
êtes d'accord sur l'idée que vous
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait on leur fait
d'accord moi on n'est pas d'accord
et questions par contre sur la couleur
du
dimanche devant nous
ça choque
c'est dur parce qu'il veut où il veut
bleus et puis moi quand une petite fille
récurrence je me souviens que
la merde ou faire
il était rose alors
mais je dis ça comme ça sans aucune
je sens que c'est un mix et l'interstice
les interlocuteurs
j'étais pro moi j'ai très envie de
répondre précisément à ce que vient de
dire françoise c'est que tous les
problèmes et ça on vit ça aujourd'hui
mais moi je le ressens moi
personnellement pratiquement en
permanence dans les propres difficultés
c'est qu'on vit en permanence
dans nos propres problèmes et nos
propres conflits face à une
confrontation qu'à la confrontation la
psychanalyse si ça va pas bien on a un
petit peu l'impression qu' on ne peut
rien résoudre de nos vies quotidiennes
on ne payerai tout simplement en parlant
entre nous deux ce qu'on vit tous les
jours sans quille est en permanente à
sanction à l'aller tic qui vient peser
en permanence sur nos décisions nous
conversation
bon je pense qu'à ce stade là je sens le
besoin de faim nous sentons besoin de
faire une mise au point
pour nous il semblait pas très
nécessaire disons peu important de
mettre les conséquences de ces problèmes
qui sont un problème relationnel sur la
table mais qu'il fallait peut-être mieux
essayer de discuter et de d'analyser et
de comprendre les causes et
justement je veux
je vous dois demander si au niveau du
public et si au niveau des gens qui nous
questionnent c'est à dire serge et
pascal ceci leur semble clair et leur
sens de satisfaisant je suis très
embarrassée parce que vous demander en
même temps et vu c'est comme ça que vous
commenciez tout à l'heure qu'on vous
dise les causes
qu'on dise quelque chose sur les causes
de votre souffrance
et en même temps vous demandez que on
fasse l'économie
de district pourrait faire apparaître la
cause parce que la cause nous n'en
savons pas beaucoup plus que vous c'est
vous qui allez nous le dira en en
parlant je pense que
je m'en suis ce que la cour n'en on a
pas mal des friches et à ce niveau là au
niveau des causes soit sage et qu'il
avoue denise à faire là dedans
toujours pour le même temps ou deux
enfin quoi vous êtes vous qu'est-ce que
vous êtes quoi vous n'êtes pas balayeur
ici venez en tant que psychanalyste
oui vous êtes bon vous êtes un individu
mais vous êtes quand même en fait aussi
psychanalyste oui ça veut dire bon savez
diriger un certain boulot une certaine
expérience juste savoir qu'on n'est pas
manipulé par des gens mais on est
manipulé par un certain nombre de parole
qu'on n'entend pas non mais les causes
pourquoi est obligatoire vous voulez
chercher dans la psychanalyse par la
psychanalyse tout dire je les cherche
dans son les aident à vous écouter
lorsque vous dites pas seulement dans ce
que vous dites parce qu'on est mal ou
que vous n'entendez pas vous en tenir
tout vous ve n'entendez pas les mots
c'est surtout après quatre phrases après
vous dit pourquoi vous à lui tu sais
quoi luttent bon comme moi et mes 10 h
15 qu'est ce que j'ai dit non j'ai pas
dit lutz ici dit lutte bon bien sûr j'ai
pu le dire mais
prendre des mots comme ça six en tout
cas là il ya dispute entre nous non non
ne sais pas
courtoisie encore
et a parlé aussi non yahoo ses amitiés
je dis rien où ces messieurs ne sais pas
s'il ya une dispute c'est que j'ai cru
sentir nos bases d'un point de vue
extérieur mais chez françoise la
sensation que d'écouter le public ça lui
faisait réentendre quelquefois les
discussions qu'elle avait avec fois avec
yvon cette tendance à tout
intellectualiser dans un coup à faire
qu'un coupe n'est plus un couple mais
finalement un problème de couple ce qui
ce qui a l'air d'être en ce moment je
trouve qu'il faut absolument secoué ce
mouvement là elle se dit a finalement un
couple ça ne se fait pas à coups de
problèmes résolus mais un coup d'amour
elle même vous disais tu as tu veux être
marginal mais tu ne te donne pas les
moyens or en fait vous restez en effet
parce que vous n'osez pas sortir dans
l'arène et la reine silvia laissé tomber
d'intelligence et fonctionner avec ce
qui n'est pas l'envers l'intelligence
mais tout simplement le coeur
merci pour
qui ça merci pour ce que vous avez dit
laisser tomber l'intelligence
important la dispute dans notre coulpe à
ce que soit vous vous disputez tous les
deux soit comme tout à l'heure vous la
dispute de place de vous hier nous sert
que tout d'un coup la dispute a lieu
entre vous et nous surprend mais ça va
ce qui s'échange là où ceux qui se
cassent la dernière j'aimerais bien
essayer de comprendre la fonction de
cette dispute aussi bien quand elle a
lyon entre vous que quand elle a lieu
contre nous
je crois que c'est une tentative de
tracts et d'expression et de
ce que j'ai une tentative de d'exprimer
ou de dissimuler je crois son actif
d'expression six tentatives de retrouver
le master eu contact enfin je le pense
je pense entre nous facile de résoudre
résoudre est vide et
je voudrais demander à yvon comment
comment est ce que vous sentez cette
cette interpellation de descendre dans
l'arène
je pense que je la sens très justement
elles sont très justes et je les sens
justement si
je crois qu'il fut pas si je suis pas
descendu plus tôt c'est que je ne savais
pas à qui j'ai de faire enfin c'est
peut-être
je pense que je peux répondre par une
image également
lorsque vous avez un
jeu c'est pas quelque chose de précieux
quelque chose de
fort et quelque chose qui est neuf
vous savez je sais pas un enfant qui a
très beaux jouets jeux très très beau
jouer quelque chose qu'il adore qu'il
affectionne qui lequel il tient je sais
pas à sa poupée son nounours
le trouve qu'il est bien le recevoir et
vraiment pour lui signifie énormément
je pense qu'il va pas le donner à
n'importe qui il va pas le prêter à
n'importe qui je pense que ce qui moi ce
qui est moins au fond
profond de mon être
il fallait que je sache avec à qui je
pouvais le nez enfin à qui je pouvais le
nez est-ce que je ce trésor qui semble
au au coeur de ce que vous avez à
défendre
le moteur de votre méfiance et même de
votre retraite est-ce que vous pouvez au
moins pour vous même lui donner des noms
parce que vous savez en quoi il consiste
je crois qui consiste à
une force c'est une force et une force
d'amour c'est une force qui est brutale
mais qui n'a pas de riz qui n'a pas de
résistance je sais pas quel jeu si j'ai
du mal à j'ai du mal à cerner parce
qu'effectivement je vais je me posais
cette question
concrètement
je vois
si simple
je vois pas bon ce que tu dis tout ce
que tu dis est vrai mais c'était c'est
complètement englobé dans quelque chose
bon ce qu'il faudrait c'est que parce
qu'il faudrait en parlant concrètement
des choses à dire que tu dis ou alors
c'est parce que tu veux pas le dire mais
si tu veux pas dire il faut foncer sage
parce que sinon on va passer moi je sais
pas enfin dans le concrètement il ya
tout est à tout ce que tu racontes et en
racontant david enfin ta vie d'enfants
donc qui faisait que effectivement tu
t'es senti blessé et il y avait il ya eu
des conséquences est si tu es bon tu t
es tu me disais que tu avais tu t'es tu
étais toujours
tu t'es battu pour pas mourir pour pas
crever pour pas il a fallu qu survivants
quand j'ai expliqué mon enfance à moi je
disais quelles conséquences ça avait sur
moi je ne sais pas mais oui tu l'as bon
alors c'est parce que tu veux pas en
parler je vois pas celui ci ils vont ils
fous mais celui-ci que tu fasse l'effort
je suis pas en train d'essayer de 2,2 de
te faire parler je voudrais eelv on sait
que tu arrives à comprendre que c'est
pas spécialement par rapport à moi j'ai
jamais dit ça et que je le dis moi oui
il ya des choses il ya des choses dans
ta vie pour comprendre de jean ii et
envoûte par les dix minutes ils vont
ensuite on supplie écoute pour les
rentes de dire je ne tarissent pas
j'essaie simplement de te dire ce que tu
m'a dit à moi
c'était plus entendre bon alors ce que
j'ai cru entendre ce que je mange à la
la la la la la la la
tu me tues yvon tu me tues tu me tues et
quand je te dis que tu me tues ne s'est
pas seulement une idée tu cours après
quelque chose moi
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi
je voudrais apprendre à danser
françoise apprenez moi
j'ai pas envie
on apprend semble ya juste ni pour la
débrancher juste mesure
plaisir c'est pas
juste ça
[Musique]
très maladroit
montre moi à oui
quelqu'un
super
[Musique]
à vrai dire j'ai toujours suivant ses
chais samendéni
grillage
[Musique]
c'est vrai
moi
ma
à
tu sors toi
et loup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
moi je voudrais vous remercier je
voudrais vous remercier d'avoir soutenu
tout au long de ce marathon de ce soir
quelque chose de vraiment très rare veut
dire le
d'avoir soutenu ce qui est aujourd'hui
encore votre désir de rencontre
2-2 n'avoir rien cacher de tout ce qui
en faisait la difficulté voire même à
certains moments l'impossibilité essaie
surtout de ça que je voulais vous
remercier parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'en montrant ce qui a aussi de
possibles et d'un possible vraiment vous
nous donner une certaine façon une leçon
de vie parce que vivre c'est vraiment se
colleter à ça
vous remercier vivant et vous remet un
style qu'on soit d'avoir fait ce long
travail avec nous ce soir non merci
aussi les téléspectateurs qui ont bien
voulu nous suivre nous accompagner
pendant cette émission et nous espérons
que ce travail fait avec eux fait devant
elle aura servi à quelque chose merci au
revoir à la prochaine édition
[Musique]